you led the 50 million dollar c round
for a company called colossal
that is focused on
de-extinction
uh this is funny relative to our
connection uh and conversation about
jurassic world
they're seeking to restore lost
ecosystems and use gene editing to
restore the
woolly mammoth to the arctic tundra
how are they going to do that
well um i met this fascinating guy at
harvard named george church
five six years ago
um and found him to be incredibly smart
uh have an
imagination um
and
he partnered up with a guy named ben lam
who's an entrepreneur
and basically
the the uh the press and to me the the
imaginative like you're capturing my
imagination by telling me you're going
to bring back the woolly mammoth and
other extinct animals and i
you know we'll see where that road leads
i'm was more interested in an investor
in the things that they're working
through
around understanding
genes and more in proteins and crispr
and all these other things because
um
being adjacent to george church and his
team as these things unfold over the
next decade i i thought was
uh the right the right thing to do
people are important here just like
investing people and seeing what the
hell they come up with absolutely i mean
you can look through history
and
um
great things are done by great people
right and companies they end up over
time becoming a logo and immediately
what you think of them but they started
out
with a person with an idea and a team
that cultivated that and made that
happen
um
and i and i think there are certain
folks that are just immensely talented
that if you can be around
them
and i also know his
and his team's
ethics in terms of you know after
spending time
talking about where the lines
are people in other countries that you
know may not have the same
process may not have the same checks and
balances are doing this and pursuing
this regardless so
at least i felt like with george and ben
and their teams they're also very
responsible people
this is where the human
side of things comes into play
i've interacted with a lot of really
brilliant people in the technology space
where you kind of
you know there's a lot of ways to feel
this out you can ask them whether they
kind of read literature you could you
can feel out how much do they really
understand
about like
human nature here
like
whatever the technology is when it
actually starts to
play
interact with society at scale
like do they have an understanding or an
intuition about how that happens some of
that requires studying history some of
that requires like just looking at the
worst and best
parts and
events in human history to understand
like hey
it doesn't always turn out like
everybody hoped
uh the technology turns out and
if a person has a depth of understanding
about
history about uh
human nature then i think
that's the right person to um
to mess with some of this cutting edge
stuff
yeah you want marcus aurelius with a phd
from mit
[Laughter]
exactly
you